take a look at this video from minnesota  where a plane had to make an emergency  landing on interstate 35.  this happened wednesday night watch this  the pilot narrowly missed several  vehicles before hitting an suv  as it skidded to a stop the woman's car  was totaled but  no one was hurt an investigation is  underway the pilot is a member of a  prize-winning  u.s precision flying team so he had that  going for him  not only that i heard that he got out of  the car and was very apologetic one to  make sure that everybody was okay i  thought that was nice his goal was to  not hit any cars  it happened at 9 15 at night you're just  driving down the road and this woman all  of a sudden there's  you know the plane lands basically on  top of her suv i can't believe what  you're seeing  you can see he tried to get around her  he did his best yeah that's why he  apologized he really didn't want to hit  anybody but  look luckily everybody's good